hello my name is chinholi
in this video i will talk about
polynomial time trace reconstruction
in the low deletion range regime this is
joint work representation
and in the other record the video and in
her
so first let me tell you what is the
trace reconstruction problem
in this problem we have an mb string x
and we pass x through the deletion
channel
this channel deletes each bit of x
independently with some probability
delta
so in this example here the channel d is
the second bit and the fifth bit
then the channel outputs the
concatenation of the surviving bits
so here it outputs one one one zero one
to give you another example uh the
channel
may delete the first bit and the second
last bit here
and then output 0 0 1 1 1 1
this time just to give you one more
example
this time only the third bit is deleted
so you get a longer output this time
okay so note that the deleted positions
in x are not revealed in the output
and also the length of each sample is
not necessarily the same
so these intersect independent samples
coming from the deletion channel
are called the traces of x
so here is the trace reconstruction
problem
we are given traces of an unknown mb
string x
and our goal is to reconstruct x exactly
with high probability
note that x is not is not allowed to be
encoded before passing it to the
deletion channel
so the basic question is to understand
how many traces
suffice to reconstruct x and whether
there is an efficient algorithm for this
task
so this problem has some applications in
computational biology
for example you can think of traces
correspond to
the mutated and dna sequences
and then the reconstruction problem
would be to reconstruct
the original dna sequence from this
mutated sequence
so here are some previous results on
this problem
so the problem was actually first
introduced by this work by batu
canon connor and mcgregor in 2004
and in this work they gave
an efficient algorithm that works for
any deletion rate that's less than one
over square root of n
later the autonomous video
and nazareth and paris independency give
an algorithm
for any deletion rate that's bounded
away from one
and the algorithm uses exponential to
enter 1 3 samples
and very recently chase managed to
improve this exponent 1 3
to 1 5th in terms of lower bound
in this other work by chase that
is that built on the work of holden and
ions
it showed that for any constant delta
the trace reconstruction problem
requires 10 to the three half
traces
so as you can see the recent works have
been focusing on improving
the sampling capacity and
for constant deletion rate and you can
see that the
algorithms are not as efficient as the
one given by
ekm here
also the lower bounds given don't seem
to hold for
sub constant deletion rate so in this
work
we asked the following question suppose
we insist
on the algorithm being efficient then
what is the largest division rate that
we can handle
and this is our result so we show that
for any constant epsilon and deletion
rate
delta that's less than one over enter
one third plus epsilon
then there is an efficient algorithm
that we have first x
with high probability using polynomial
number of traces
and time
okay so our algorithm is very similar
to bkkm which is also alignment based
and it improves from um
so it improves on this work because
our work handles a larger division rate
so if we actually improve the deduction
rate from
n to the one over n one over square root
of n to
one over enter one third
so while this improvement may seem
not much note that when delta is
roughly 1 over square root of n then
already the previous upper bound
uses exponential to the end of 1 6
traces
and we believe this alignment base
approach given by s and
ekm could potentially work for larger
deletion rate
so let me now give you the algorithm
overview
and before that i need to introduce a
notion called testers
these are just some non-subwords in
x that is of some repeated
repeated constant size pattern
so just to give an example for example
if x
is a string then here is a one desert
because it consists of some consecutive
uh sequence of ones which is of length
at least one of a delta
and then here we have uh
zero one desert because this is are just
zero one zero one zero one zero one and
we have at least one over delta many of
them
so our algorithm alternates between the
following two procedure
the first one is called bitwise majority
alignment
in short is bma so
it we construct x up to a destroyed
and then the next procedure is called
finance
and it tries to locate and align some
new traces to the end of
the desert
so here is a simulation on an example
so this gray x is our unknown x
at first we draw some fresh traces and
then we run
bma on these traces
then bme will return a candidate output
x hat
so x hat may not agree with x but what
we know for certain is
that is going to agree with x
up to the first n b's of the first
desert
so now we know there is a destruct index
then we switch to finance and finance
will tell us
the end point of this desert which is
here
it will also try to align the traces
but that it will i mean it locates the
position where the
endpoint of the desert appears in each
phrase
so once we know the endpoint of a desert
in x
then we can fill out this piece because
we know the pattern of the tester
when we run bme
so now we switch back to uh
running bma and then it will continue
running bma on these new traces and then
we will
it will be constructed up to the second
desktop
in the x
again we know that is correct up to the
first end piece of this second desert
and now we switch to fine end and find
the end
location of this desert and locate this
endpoint
in some new traces
so once we locate once we have located
this endpoint
we can switch to bma and continue
run reconstructing x and because now
there's no desert
in the end in the string
so we can finish running the algorithm
so let me now say more about the bma
algorithm
so this algorithm was introduced by uh
the work of batu at all so it takes some
not
n traces as input and then what it does
is it
outputs a candidate x hat of x
so in this work we prove the following
guarantee
first of course rpm runs efficiency
and second is that we show that if at
the beginning
most of the traces are aligned correctly
then with high probability
the candidate x hat is correct up to the
first m piece
of of the first desert in x
so as you can see uh the algorithm is
very robust
and this rows robustness is comes from
majority in
algorithm okay
so let me now explain how the algorithm
works
so at the beginning the algorithm would
set up some pointers for each trace
and each pointer points at the beginning
of each race
then we will recover x bit by bit
for the first bit it will take the
majority of the pointed locations in the
trace
so here we have the majority
is zero so it will output a zero
and then it will update the pointers as
follows if the pointer output
gives us gives us the correct answer
then we will
move the pointer forward by one
and if it doesn't then it stays through
so in the intuition is that if the
traces
if the pointers agree with the output
then we think of this trace as being
aligned correctly
so we just move the pointer forward
otherwise
we think of it as misalight and then it
will stay still
just to try to correct this misalignment
so let me simulate a few more steps of
the algorithm
so now we try to recover the second bit
and this time all the traces are
pointing to one
so we output one and then we update all
the pointers by moving them forward by
one
and in the next step this time the
majority is one
because three of them are pointing to
one so we upgrade to one
and then we update the pointers as
before
and then we just keep them keep running
this algorithm using the same principle
okay so let me
talk about the analysis of the algorithm
so in the old analysis by
bkkm they show that
if the decision rate delta is at most
one over square root of n
and also if x has no one decisions
or zero dashes these are just a long
sequence of
consecutive ones or zeros then bma
actually outputs x correctly with
hyper-ability
so in their analysis they rely on the
facet
no two consecutive bits in x are deleted
and that's why it only works when delta
is less than one over square root of
n
it's not hard to see that actually bma
does not work or will not work
when there are
one desert and zero dashes
just consider the o1 string
each time the pointer of each tray is it
trace is going to
move forward each time but after running
about one of the delta many steps then
each
trace is going to miss some bs because
of
deletion so the algorithm would never
output the correct number of ones
as the input as the unknown input
so in this work you will give a new
analysis of the bma algorithm
we show that when the deletion rate is
at
most say one over enter the epsilon
and if x has no s deserts
for any constant size s
then the average of outputs x correctly
with high probability
so here we are making a stronger
assumption than the one made in bkkm
and that's why when we deal with the
desert when we try to locate
the end of the desert we have to do more
work
so to help and our analysis we have the
following
visualization of the trace y
the way we think of it is as follows
so for trace y we draw we first write
down x
and then we cross out the deleted piece
in y
and we have two pointers one the left
pointer is pointing to the bit that we
are trying to recover
another white pointer is pointing to the
location
pointed by the pointer in the algorithm
so so here we introduce a distance
notepad
a notion called distance which measures
the amount of misalignment at time t
and this is basically just the distance
between the current pointer
in the trace and the bit that we are
trying to recover
so in in this example the distance is 3.
and in our analysis we show the
following invariant
so we show that if x has no decisions
then we have high probability at each
step of the algorithm
the distance of each trace is actually
non-negative
and also the sum of the ordered
the distance of all traces is
at most the number of trays divided by
10.
so from this it's not hard to see that
most of the traces are aligned
okay that was all i wanted to say about
bma
so now we move to the analysis the
algorithm of
find end
so define an algorithm takes a few
things as input
first it takes a reconstructed prefix of
x-hat
then you also draw some new traces not
any of them
and it also has access to the deletion
channel
because during the execution of the
algorithm
is going to draw some additional traces
and this find an algorithm is going to
output two things
one is the candidate endpoint of the
desktop index
and it also tries to align these new
traces
so it will output some candidate
locations of where x
and the endpoint of the tester appears
in each of the trees
so the guarantee given by the algorithm
is that
finance uses polynomial many
traces and it's going to
and it it's going to give you the
correct endpoint
and most of the pointers are going to
align
it's analyzed correctly
defining algorithm is actually a bit
delicate so i will
only give you a rough idea of how it
works
so as a first step the algorithm will
try to find an
interval so that most of the traces
is going to contain this endpoint in
this interval
so this interval is of length sigma
which is about
square root of delta n log
n and this
note that this length is basically how
far
the point x n can deviate from its
expected location
in a random trace so in other words you
can think of
this as giving a course estimate of the
expected location
of x and
so once we have this interval then we
try to
use
we try to find a signature subword
called sig
in the unknown x that contains the end
point of the desolate
okay so uh the
definition of signature is a bit
delicate
but um essentially
we want signature to be suspect very
different from
the pattern in in the desert
because in the next step we try to use
this to locate
the end point in the new traces
but of course this is not always
possible because
sometimes this endpoint may get deleted
in the trace
and if this happens then we have to
output something
like an error or something
so to so now we can use
three to align the pointers
in the new traces
and we can also run three on
polynomially many traces
to do and then do an empirical estimate
of the expected location of the trees
so here we have to be a bit careful in
the algorithm because
of the fact that three is
sometimes is going to reach it when it
cannot locate
the endpoint so we have to do some
scaling
when we do the empirical estimation
so here i want to mention that each of
these three steps relies on the vector
sigma is much less than one over delta
and the reason is that we want to ensure
in most traces
there's no deletion in
[Music]
in the interval j or in more generally
we don't want any deletion
in interval of this
of this width
and this is the reason why we require
dns
so this is the reason why it only works
when delta is at most one over enter one
3.
so that's all i wanted to say about
finance
and here is a summary of our result
we show that for any constant epsilon
and deletion rate
one over n to the one-third plus epsilon
there's an algorithm that we call first
x
efficiency that means using polynomial
many traces
and time and at the high level
our algorithm alternates between two
procedures
the first one is the piecewise majority
alignment
which correctly we construct x up to the
first desktop index
and then we use the next procedure
finance to locate the end point of the
desert
and also we locate where this endpoint
appears in each of the fresh traces
and as mentioned before this analysis
for finance
requires um this square root of n
delta to be much less than one over
delta
and this is the reason why our algorithm
only works when delta is less than
one over n to the one third
so um obvious open problem is that
whether we can
overcome this barrier so we would like
an algorithm an efficient algorithm that
was for
for example say delta equals to one over
n to the
point three two or more generally
we were hoping whether we can achieve
delta to be
any polynomial
so this is all i wanted to say about
this work
thank you for listening